I told you before that any number raised to force 0 equals 1
If x ^ 0 = 1
I gave you a proof explaining this situation
If we have 3 ^ 1
It will equal 3
3 ^ 2 = 9
3 ^ 3 = 27
If each time we lower the value of the force, we divide by 3
27 3 3 = 9
9 3 3 = 3
Then 3 3 3 = 1
So we get the output of 3 ^ 0
This is the way we think
We will need this way to think
How the characteristics of the foundations work
For example, I told you that a ^ b × a ^ c
= a ^ b + c
Now, what will happen if it is c = 0
Or what happens if we have a ^ b × a ^ 0?
Well, according to this property, these will be equal
a ^ b + 0, which equals a ^ b
If a ^ b × a ^ 0 = a ^ b
If you divide the parties on a - let me rewrite
This is - a ^ b × a ^ 0, if we use this property
The output would be a ^ b, would not it? b + 0 = b
If you divide the two sides on a ^ b, what do you get?
In the left side, we will have
a ^ 0, right?
These are deleted
a ^ 0 = 1
You can use a similar proof that applies to all
Characteristics of bases, in which the numbers are raised to the force 0
Equal to 1
This is logical when we divide on 3, every step we take
Decrease the value of the exponent
And will always succeed
When we have 3 ^ -1, we have seen this in
The last offer is equal to 1/3 ^ 1
Or 1/3
If again, move from 3 to 0 to 1/3
We divide by 3 at a time
If this is so logical to some degree where that
3 ^ 0 = 1
But that makes a gap
What is the output of 0 ^ 0?
This is a strange idea
That is, we will beat 0 by itself 0 times
This depends on the context you use
Sometimes people can say that the value is not known, but others
They are many, at least in my area of ​​expertise, they will say that output
Equals 1
The reason - though this is not
Obviously, you can write 0 ^ 0 at
The search engine is online and will give you a result
Even if it is not obvious, the reason
The output ID in this way is
The success of some formulas
One formula is the two-edged equation
This will work when you find a double-edged equation, and I will not explain it
Now, if the bottom line is 0 ^ 0 = 1
This is interesting and you have to think about what
Means?
Let us now talk a bit about other characteristics
So we can use them all when you do a group solution
Of the questions, I have told you in the last offer what
It means that a number is raised to a negative force
a ^ -1, or maybe I should say
a ^ -b = 1 / a ^ b
Let's apply this to a set of realistic examples
3 ^ -3 = 1/3 ^ 3
It is equal to 1/3 × 3 × 3
Ie = 1/27
If I ask you what is the output of 1/3 ^ -2?
Well, that's worth it
1/1/3 ^ 2
We get rid of the negative and turn it over
1 / -
How much output 1/3 × 1/3?
1/9
Equally - this is 1 1 1/9 =
1 × 9, if = 9
This is very logical, because 1/3, remember, 1/3
Is equal to 3 ^ -1, is not it?
3 ^ -1 = 1/3 ^ 1
Equal to 1/3
If we compensate for 1/3 B3 ^ -1, the output is
(3 ^ -1) ^ - 2
These words are equal
If we use one of the properties we learned in
The first lesson, we will get an output
These are the disadvantages
If it equals 3 ^ -1, × -2
It becomes positive 2, and the result is 9
This is something structured as all the characteristics of the foundations
Connected to each other in a beautiful way, no
Conflict with each other
It does not matter which feature you use, in the end you'll get it
On the right answer, as long as you do not
No error
Now, the last thing I would define is a concept
Assi Al Kasri
If we had a number raised to a breaking force - suppose that
We have a ^ 1 / b
I'll know that
This equals the root of the b for a
So let me be clearer here
I will use the numbers here
If I say 4 ^ 1/2, that means
Square root of 4
This is equal, if intended as the root of course
Equals 2
If I say, I'll be clear, MRI
This is equivalent to Cubic root of 8
And that, to some degree, is one of the things
The nuisance in the foundations
Here I say, what is the number that if hit him himself 3 times
Will be 8?
If you assume that x = 8 ^ 1/3, this is
Equivalent to x ^ 3
= 8
How can I know that these two phrases are equal?
Well, I can lift both ends of the equation
Force 3
If applied on the left side and raised to force 3
And then the right side, what will I get?
On the left side, I'll get x ^ 3
The right side, get 8 ^ 1/3 × 3
Ie 3/3, equal to 1
If x = 8 ^ 1/3, what is x?
Well, 2 × 2 × 2 = 8
There is no easy way, especially when dealing with
Root IV, or V, or when we have decimal numbers
For her account
You will probably need most of the time to calculator to help you calculate this
But numbers such as 8 ^ 1/3, or 16 ^ 1/4, or 27 ^ 1/3
Not difficult to calculate
If this, I'll be clear, = 2
Now, let's make things a little harder
How much product 27 ^ -1 / 3?
Do not worry too much
I will solve it step by step
When we have negative power, this is
Equals 1/27 ^ 1/33
These are equal
We get rid of the negative signal and get the
1 / All this
Then what is the output of 27 ^ 1/3?
Well, what is the number that if you hit it yourself 3 times you get 27?
It's 3
This is equal to 1/3
Not bad
Now I will be a little more difficult
To become a bit arduous
Let me solve an interesting example
How much output 8 ^ 2/3?
This sounds scary
All you have to remember is that this is similar
It can be solved using base rules
It is the same (8 ^ 2) ^ 1/3
How do I know this?
Well, if you hit those two
If 8 ^ 2/3 equals 8 ^ 2, then
We raise the whole amount of force 3
But we can imagine it in another way
This is equal to (8 ^ 1/3) ^ 2
Because any way we use it, when we hit the foundations
We'll get 8 ^ 2/3
Let's check that we are
We will get the same value
If 8 ^ 2 = 64
Then we increase the amount of force 1/3
We have here, 8 ^ 1/3
We have already created the output
Equals 2, because 2 ^ 3 = 8
If it is 2 ^ 2
Now, how much output is 64 ^ 1/3?
What is the number that you hit yourself 3 times, giving you the output 64?
Well, 4 × 4 × 4 = 64, or 4 ^ 3
= 64, which means 4 =
64/1/3
Equals 4
Luckily, 2 ^ 2 also equals 4
So the way we follow is not important
Where you can take the square root and then the cube root, or
You can take the third root and then square it
And you will get the same output
Now, everything I have dealt with
It was actual numbers
Let me now deal with issues
Contains variables
So we want to take some phrases and
Make sure that
The output is non-negative
So let me say x + 3 / x ^ -7
This issue can be seen in several ways
We can consider it x ^ 3 × 1
/ x ^ -7
How much output 1 / x ^ -7?
This equals x ^ 7, right?
If we have 1 divided by a number, you can get rid of the 1
By placing a negative signal against the exponent
But if you put a negative signal against
-7, you get x ^ 7
This can be simplified to become x ^ -3 ×
x ^ 7
And then we can gather the foundations, so we have
x ^ 4
Now we'll use another method, which is a really logical way
Where we can lay the foundations
Well, we have the same foundation
So we have x ^ -3
- - 7
Well, 3 - 7, is equal
3 + 7 = x ^ 4
And the latter way, - I mean, it exists
More than one way can be followed here
We can say x ^ 3 /
x ^ -7-- Sorry, not -x -
/ x ^ -7
Well, x ^ -3 equals 1 / x ^ 3
This phrase - x 1 / x ^ -7
If this equals
1 / x ^ 3 × x ^ -7
You can collect the foundations, and become
1/3 - 7 = x ^ -4
And then - if we get rid of the inverse, we take
Inverted, we can put a negative signal for this
Negative, and becomes positive - so it is
Output x ^ 4
If it does not matter the way we follow, in case we are consistent with
The rules, we'll get x ^ 4
Let us now resolve a complex issue
And then I thought we would have done what was required of us today
To move: 3x ^ 2 × y ^ 3/2
We will divide it by x × y ^ 1/2
Again, this equates to 3 x x expressions
If 3 × x ^ 2 / x × y ^ 3/2
/ y ^ 1/2
Well, this equals 3 × - how much value
x ^ 2 / x?
Or x ^ 2 / x ^ 1?
This is equal to x ^ 2 - 1
And then these become y ^ 3/2 - 1/2
So what is the final product?
It's 3 x x
2 - 1 = 1 - and can type x here - × 3/2
- 1/2 = 2/2
If y ^ 2/2 equals
2/2 are the same y
This is worth 3xy
However, I advise you to solve more
Examples of this
But you'll see that this is just the use of rules that
I explained it in the final lessons, so that you can
To simplify any exponential phrase
That's all I have now, see you soon
I have told you in many lessons that any number raised to 0 is equal to 1